grace
is with us in illinois hi grace welcome
to the dave ramsey show
hi rachel hi dave thank you for taking
my call sure
um i am 32 years old
i am not married and i just finished my
full emergency fund so i'm super excited
about that
i am currently renting an apartment and
my parents are encouraging me to save up
and buy a house or
a condo sometime by the end of the year
but i'm nervous about doing that because
i don't know what my life will look like
in five years like to me
buying a house is something long term
and i don't
since i don't know what my life will
look like if i'm married or whatever
um i don't want to be stuck with a house
and have to sell it really fast
so my question is do you see a problem
with continuing to rent for a while
and just start investing into my 401k
now or should i take my parents advice
and buy something as soon as possible
if you bought something why do you
perceive that you would be stuck with it
or have to sell it quickly
why would you have to do that you're in
good financial shape you could sell it
slowly
yeah um well right now i'm thinking for
myself right so if i
um if i were to get married within the
next couple years or so
i i would think that if i wanted to move
to a bigger house or whatnot if i wanted
to start a family
then that would be kind of pressuring to
to sell fast
yeah wouldn't be fast it would just be
that we would have to sell but i mean it
wouldn't be like you'd have to sell it
within 30 days or you're gonna
you know be foreclosed on or something
you would just put it up for sale
right so you know you don't want to buy
something then that wouldn't be
marketable you want to buy something in
a kind of a that you have a good feeling
that it would sell
easily when you get ready to resell it
okay so you do agree that i should
instead of just continuing to rent
for a while i should buy something i
should be saving up to buy something
under those circumstances the
circumstances being that you buy
something
that is um going to be easy to sell when
you get ready to move to the next
transition in your life now you
mentioned getting married in two years
are you in a
relationship that's indicating that or
you're just thinking that might happen
out there somewhere
i'm just thinking i'm not in a
relationship okay
yeah i don't know right yeah i probably
would i mean i think investing in real
estate is a great option and again
you're in good financial shape and
just like you were saying david just
sell it if you choose to move it or
maybe if you do get married you'll
decide to live there
yeah don't buy something weird you know
buy something that's
kind of uh generic that a lot of people
might buy that doesn't take a unique
buyer to buy it
that's easy to sell in other words